why do we find other people's saliva so
gross we each produce about two bathtubs
full of the stuff every year so why
don't we freak out when even one drop of
someone else's saliva comes near us
getting the odd splash of saliva from a
spinny talker isn't gonna kill you but
what if you were submerged in a large
volume of it what kind of dangers would
you be exposed to this is what if and
here's what would happen if you jumped
into a pool filled with human saliva the
average sized swimming pool in America
has a volume of about 51,000 liters if
you were to try to fill this pool with
just your own spit it would take you
about 93 years since you only produce
about one and a half liters per day so
you're gonna need some other people to
help you out and by some people we mean
thousands of them continuously spitting
into the pool at the same time but even
with all these people it would still
take a long time to produce enough
saliva to fill an entire pool so is
there anything else we could do to speed
up the process and which you really want
to dive in once it was filled
[Music]
let's say you're getting really
impatient as you wait for your
volunteers to fill up this pool here are
a couple of tips to increase everyone's
saliva production for starters and this
one's pretty obvious drink more water
then start handing out as much chewing
gum as you can
chewing cues the salivary glands to get
to work and start producing more saliva
also you're going to need to tell your
volunteers to avoid coffee alcohol and
anything to do with tobacco or vaping as
they can all cause a severely dry mouth
and don't worry if that's not speeding
things up enough we've still got another
trick up our sleeve if you think about
food see it or smell it a reflex signal
is sent to a portion of your brain
called the medulla oblongata that's
where your salivary centers are so if
you were to place a bunch of food that
looks and smells fantastic around the
pool that would fire up everyone's nerve
signals to get that saliva flowing once
the pool is completely full all you need
to do is dive in but as you stare down
at the lukewarm slime bath of DNA
samples you'll start to realize that you
don't really know anything about the
substance you're about to jump into so
maybe you should get acquainted first
saliva is 98% water with the other 2%
consisting of things like bicarbonate
sodium and potassium plus other active
ingredients saliva not only adds some
lubrication to help us swallow our food
it also protects our teeth and gums from
stomach acids and Ward's off the
billions of microbes that are in our
mouth at any given time
yeah that's right the human mouth is a
pretty gross place it can contain over
700 different varieties of bacteria and
one of the easiest ways to transfer
those bacteria to other people is
through your spit and that's what makes
this whole saliva pool idea pretty
dangerous some of the fun things that
can be passed on through saliva include
colds flu virus herpes hepatitis B and
hepatitis C avian flu and Ebola so if
you want to avoid all that you're going
to want to make sure that you have no
open cuts or wounds when you jump into
the pool
but when definitely keep your mouth
closed even if you could confirm that
every one of your spit donors was clean
of the conditions above you still
wouldn't want to swallow mouthfuls of
their saliva right not only would it be
gross but it would also make you
dehydrate it because saliva contains
high concentrations of proteins and
enzymes drinking it would cause the
fluids in your body to flow towards it
and not towards your dehydrated cells as
for the actual experience of jumping
into the saliva pool it'd be just like
swimming and thick frothy water oh and
you'd probably want to wear nose plugs
because saliva carries so much bacteria
it can also have quite an unpleasant
smell it's something you'd want to wash
off immediately after your swim because
the scent would only get worse as it
dries on you but don't get us wrong when
it comes to swimming in bodily fluids
you could do far worse than a pool of
saliva but that sounds like a story for
another what if